alberto las sanciones europeas y
estadounidenses son contundentes pero
llegan tras un movimiento de rusia y no
antes de él llegan quizás demasiado
tarde
yo creo que era un escenario previsible
puesto que nunca funcionó al final la
demanda cero de rusia la demanda cero de
rusia era que era un pedido de garantía
a la otan de no expandirse al este de
europa de manera que si esto no no no
estuvo nunca ni siquiera en una
posibilidad de un min 63 obviamente que
el escenario se iba a deteriorar más
bueno ayer se deterioró con el
reconocimiento de la independencia por
parte de moscú a la república de lugares
y del don es allí y como consecuencia de
este reconocimiento desde el acuerdo de
asistencia de cooperación y amistad que
firmara rusia con estas repúblicas que
viene la respuesta de occidente hoy en
las en esta panda de sanciones por parte
de eeuu más sus aliados y yo diría que
esta es una primera banda de sanciones y
yo creo que la posibilidad de una
diplomacia queda abierta para la
diplomacia queda abierta porque estos
territorios ya ucrania los perdió de
2014 y ahora viene una afirmación de
esas la pregunta que uno se hace y aquí
yo diría que bien vendrían las segundas
eventualmente las segundas bandas de
sanciones es qué pasa si se deteriora la
situación militar a partir de ahora más
de lo que está y rusia va finalmente por
el óblast del dones y el o blas de
lugansk es decir por las regiones que
van mucho más allá de las repúblicas es
proclamada independiente esto obviamente
no solamente desataría una catarata de
sanciones muy muy dañinas para rusia
puesto que aquí quedaría afectada la
posibilidad de recibir ingresos rusia
por sus principales materias primas sino
que se deterioró la seguridad
internacional
alberto el propio olaf scholz ha
reconocido que esta decisión sobre el
nord stream 2 puede traer consecuencias
también en alemania y putin tildó la
decisión de error quién puede estar
perdiendo más con la paralización del
gasoducto rusia o alemania y el resto de
europa
bueno yo creo que los principales
perdedores son rusia y alemania y aquí
diría que hay un hecho funcional para
eeuu puesto que eeuu hace tiempo que
desea que se modere la relación en el
segmento energético entre rusia y
alemania- de manera que que más
funcional que este momento para que
finalmente no prosiga la cooperación
energética entre entre estos dos actores
y tradicionalmente salvo en las guerras
mundiales siempre tuvieron una buena
relación de manera que ahora europa se
encuentra y alemania en particular que
es el motor de la unión europea se
encuentra en una información complicada
puesto que tendrán que obtener nuevas
fuentes de suministros y yo creo que
este también era un objetivo estratégico
del primo interpares de la opción